[Music]
New York City New York Madison Square
Garden and so I implore all of you to
take a step back and realize that
whatever excuse you're gonna tell me
that your parents were alcoholics that
you were molested as a child that you
grew up in a [ __ ] country that you
didn't have a mentor when you were a kid
I respect the piss out of that and I
believe it do I believe that there are
advantages for being white males of
course I do it's black and white but do
I also recognize that if anybody that
looks like you ever made it that that
needs to be an important debate and do I
realize even more importantly that every
one of you can be practical and pay your
dues being a single mom taking care of
three kids but still the fact the fact
that you can lay in bed at 10:00 p.m. to
1:00 in the morning and do [ __ ] on this
is so [ __ ] mind-boggling and is so
fundamentally disrespected as a
collective in this room that I implore
you to take one big step back and
realize that Grammy didn't have it this
good you have to do the right things and
you have to eat [ __ ] you have to eat
[ __ ] guys get into eating [ __ ] I mean it
though I mean it I mean it I worked all
of my 20s and early 30s like I didn't
buy stuff
I worked every hour I didn't do anything
cool and I was building my dad's
business for him I eat [ __ ] real [ __ ]
stinky ass [ __ ] you know and I
everybody trying to get there so fast
you want to you want to have a great
mentor as a youngster find somebody you
admire and bring them 100% of value for
six and a half years and then see how it
plays out six and a half years because
when you're 28 and a half you're still
young as [ __ ] cuz what's the alternative
the alternative how do I feel motivated
cuz I'm because four hundred trillion
two one
gratitude like I'm thankful for what I
have whenever I had something I love
when people like easy for you now know
from the get I cried when I got to Star
Wars figures instead of one when I was
six cuz I couldn't believe my parents
could afford to do that
like I'm grateful I'm grateful gratitude
gratitude like somebody's always got it
worse and as long as that's the case
then I'm good it's I and don't forget I
like setbacks I want them to judge me
I'm actually really in kind of romantic
about having a pretty big setback I
don't play that way I'm far less risky
than people realized the way I work but
I'd be excited in a weird way if I had a
big setback because then everybody would
start writing [ __ ] like oh I knew it
Oh see see that would so motivate me
because rising back up like a phoenix
and then sticking it to their [ __ ]
mouth would be phenomenal
is there I think about like what the
[ __ ] just happened I try to understand
what happened and I try not to do it
again yeah guys all of you were in
meetings and powerpoints and making
structure for excuses to not do I have
five minute meetings because most
meetings take five minutes I don't need
to [ __ ] for seven eat some celery
for three like make a joke about Karen
for five and like dick around for
another eight get [ __ ] done this is all
about what's going on in your own head
this is all about how you play I'm
insular my level of zero give a [ __ ]
about your opinion is extraordinary
Wow I want to do the behavior that
really maps to you saying nice things
about me
you know like everybody's just just not
in control because they're not in their
own head I'm insular and so when I make
a mistake I own it and I really own it
I'm not pointing fingers if somebody on
my team made the mistake which happens
every day I hired that person I
empowered that person to make a decision
and so like I own my [ __ ] period scarlet
letter for [ __ ] days and I wear it
proudly what what's your [ __ ] opinion
about it
[ __ ] you let's do one more
when do you quit your job and go in when
you can afford it happiness is so
unbelievably addictive and it makes me
so sad that so many of you created
golden handcuffs for yourself that
aren't a letting you leave your job
because you need to make a hundred
thirty thousand a year now because you
wanted seven hundred more square feet in
your apartment where you wanted a BMW
instead of a Toyota and so you're not
happy because you wanted two or three
things that mean absolutely nothing I
promise you when you've tasted both when
you both when you meet people that have
tasted both I make a hundred eighty
thousand a year and I have stuff but I'm
not happy and then I went making ninety
four thousand a year but I'm doing what
I love and I'm super happy and I have a
little less stuff it's not even close to
a debate so I implore all of you to
really dig deep inside of yourselves and
try to figure out why you need that
stuff I'm gonna save you time you're
trying to close an insecurity gap let me
give you another huge hint everybody
else sucks [ __ ] - so do you
hey guys just gave my first talk ever at
Madison Square Garden in the theater
next up the whole [ __ ] garden anyway
uh it went really well I'm super happy
with it I'm sure you guys will see it at
some point in its entirety talk about
some other stuff had a little different
cadence same old [ __ ] but a little bit
different which kind of makes it fun so
the rock is much solidly into it babban
liked it more that's mainly why I like
Babb and more than the D Rock right off
you how do you like you like babban
morning throughout - eh you know what it
is it's the rocks got a big head like
let's call it is you do this is real
like some people say it no no I say it
I'm speaking here in a little bit your
brother hi how are you oh good see ya
blog yes this man right here literally
one of my favorites you know obviously
has been kind of influencers thought
leaders personalities that I've
interacted with in the last decade but
we don't get to spend a ton of time
together because we're both doing our
thing but hey he looks great like
seriously dude you look a lot better I
mean I like you you always kind of look
good no no you always look good but you
you've tightened it up little here a
little here a little here I mean it's
pretty good man he's looking great what
listen like you know I gotta I gotta say
the truth anyway nonetheless really one
of my favorite guys hasn't matter of
fact hadn't had an incredible has an
incredible show but I was on it on Chase
Jarvis live like 40 years ago man kings
and it's very difficult to listen it's
why Facebook created a drink and doesn't
allow you to see everything right that
was fat Gary and and I'm just a fan and
so if you don't know what he's doing
make sure you follow them up bad and
let's make sure we link it all this
stuff up thank you and I think that in
the creative field the thing that has
hurt so many people I care about is they
want to rest on experience or awards
that are arbitrary by the way or degrees
or something other than the market you
may not like it but the market always
chooses what I meant in what was when I
was be what would be as an order and I
think there's also this dramatic
you know a lot of people say I can't do
this I'm not this there's some punk who
is 17 years old with a camera and she's
gonna kick my ass on end you're giving
away trade secrets and it's unfair and I
think as photographers when I came into
this real long time ago it was very much
closed it was about secrets and I'm not
gonna bring in a an assistant because
they're gonna learn from me and they're
even throwing my special lighting stuff
and then they're gonna go out and then
they're going to use that against me to
take money I literally have death
threats and I'm not trying to
overdramatize of it but well you're a
pretty bad guy from people who have said
that I'm taking money bite by
creativeLIVE we've given away three or
four billion minutes of free education
and the Internet has given away way more
yes like this is like like I don't
understand what people are debating like
information has been commoditized you
have to wrap your head around it yeah
that's just what I mean you're more than
welcome to live in your own head and
create excuses the problem is nobody
gives a [ __ ]
let me say something that might be a
huge unlock 99% of people don't do
anything about the free information the
reason I give away all my best stuff is
because nobody does anything about it
which leaves plenty for me to still do
let me tell you one other thing about
those 1% they were gonna win anyway
you can't stop winners from winning my
friends and then you can educate the
other 99% and get all the admiration and
leave a wonderful legacy and live a
fulfilled life that's the model B in the
yes business Instagram yes filters yes
going live yes snapchat yes t pH yes yes
yes yes why are you so fancy with your
time like really you don't have time for
this but yet you have the ambition to
get the luxuries that come along with
being independent we do not map our
actions to our mouths if you have
aspirations to win to cry
[ __ ] to do it the way you want to do it
you need to be in the yes business I at
this point have achieved enormous things
and every day I deploy humility to
download a new app and taste it yet I
see creatives always saying no and they
come up with some arbitrary [ __ ] of
why it's not pure and then they get run
over
thank you Pisan let's go what you want
to go further let's go oh you went live
the student went live on us what up
Instagram one life maybe just stealing
phones around here is how we do it
[Music]
all right phenomenal day double camera
down great great day he rocked like the
second one better but he had the weird
angle you won't even like looking at me
Babbitt where were you the other angle
thank God anyway great day loves
everybody
super happy with it give a lot of good
advice today
[Music]